you know i know you auditioned for band
of brothers and you got it and it you
know you just changed your life
i also tested for it with tom hanks and
i remember the building where i walked
in and yeah
you're probably there that day when when
spielberg when there were all the people
who were
who had sort of at the beginning of
their career then there were always
sort of there was eight or nine
superstars that were in there and we
were all kind of going well we're not
gonna ever get hired yeah i i you know
what i remember going in there and uh
the lantana building was that it i
remember it was just
like this little room you went into a
room and then there was another room to
the right
right you go in and tom hanks was like
get in here
and he just sat there and we read and
then i came back and he was mixing and
matching and
he got ready because he goes how do you
feel i feel good he was just so sweet
and
what what do you remember about the
process because at this point
you really were still at cal institute
right yeah i got
i just got out that was to
99 yeah uh because we sh we started
again well actually it was probably
1998. so you were like 29
and then 30. yeah no
30 i was 35 when i did it oh wow
you look a lot younger yeah yeah yeah
that's been a blessing
yeah awkward times but a blessing
um i remember like all of it
um and it was insane i was doing uh
i was working on sitcom at the time
doing just a day gig
and they they let me out in the morning
to go do it
um because i knew what it was but they
were like if anything else comes up
this rest of this week for you can't so
i let them know that and
and because we're filming like taped on
a thursday and a friday
and so you know meg was like yeah if
it goes any further it's not you know
you're not gonna hear anything for
a good couple of weeks you know so we
the first thing was happened like we
went in and then they did as you were
saying that mix and match
part of it and there may have been it
may have come back twice
i may have may have come back a second
time to see meg
because they read us all for the same
two or three parts right initially
that were not the roles that we were
going to play they were just stuff that
was more flushed out i know if you
remember
uh some of the stuff we read was like
with stuff that was not in the
in the show it was stuff like back in
town uh it was in toccoa
before they left they went overseas and
it was in real time and it wasn't just
training they had like
it was kind of what they did in the
pacific it was some of the a slice of
life at home
and then the slice of life of
they're playing around i think with that
early on and i think they realize they
just need to do just
just the men in training with each other
and build that relationship
but i remember we went in and uh
i read i think the compton stuff the
buck compton stuff was the stuff
it was it was a nice scene in a big
monologue
um so you're kind of like they were like
just play with it right you know
because we weren't auditioning for buck
content right you know everybody was
reading
the same two same thing right and uh and
then when we came back that's when we
got the different material
and he started splitting this up and
mixing and matching and you know
certain roles and there were some you
can even see with the guys the way they
looked like at the time you know
sort of you know dark air and lean and
shorter
and there was like four or five guys
that were almost interchangeable
uh in the audition process and then
there were some guys who were definitely
you know your bucks and your bulls and
you know and those guys that were
iconically described as
or were described iconically as as
certain sizes
and you know james maddio who played
perkane who's
um much much smaller than me i love you
jimmy it's not an insult
um you just you just are um
there's no way he would have been hired
to play bull or buck
um and and vice versa there's no way i
would have been hired to
play perconti but there were uh it was a
chunk in the middle that that sort of
was interchangeable i think those guys
were kind of slugging it out for
you know the same or different roles but
in the same grouping
right um and then i remember when we all
got back
and we got called in for our mix and
match uh
uh call back how nervous were you by the
way
uh pretty nervous you know but but
probably not as nervous as i should have
been because i'm
so stupid i didn't really know what you
know we didn't really know what it was
yet we know you know it was tom hanks
and steven spielberg so initially i was
enough of something like this you're
kind of like this is going to be a
career changer
like you don't you don't care and i say
this with all respect because
it comes back around i didn't give a
about these guys
like in the sense of like some sort of
historical context or the families or
some legacy
i was like this i'm going to
work with tom hanks and steven
spielberg
exactly yes that's the first thought
because you're not
you're not seeing the whole project in
this context um
once we we went through uh we paired up
mixed in mastering stephen was actually
at the final one filming uh an old
vhs or probably whatever the
state-of-the-art thing
was at the time and he's like you know
doing handheld stuff and kind of
moving around us and everything and um
we came in and there was a bunch of guys
there who were auditioning who were
stars
and then there was a bunch of us who
were not yeah and
that they obviously made a very specific
choice to go with
people who were not associated with any
other things necessarily in their career
except for david schwimmer
and and choose sort of no-name
guys to to become these guys so people
would know
them as that not go oh there's there's
you know whoever
you